here comes Kyrie go to the halfway mark
2nd quarter Kyrie in the paint
good pass Anjali for 2
[Music]
[Applause]
that shot and I think it surprised and
you got that open now Kyrie picked up by
watch oh he's going to select it again
another state to armoire
it's Katie big Adama chemical taking
itself
two veterans know how to make to play
work
Kairi he hypnotizes two guys
[Applause]
he made the bounce back leo ones at his
best yes free for the West curving gets
over the time line drives underneath
great pass to Tatum closest
[Applause]
here's the ramp ten seconds goes to the
quarter
[Applause]
look for the time shot and he does just
her time out to all 8.6 remaining in
regulation
33 for Irving 34 for wall he'll take a
long 3 unbelievable Kyrie Irving his
fourth three-pointer of the game the
two-for-one situation potentially Durant
goes around the world and punches it all
over at vodka this former OKC teammate
defense the butler with dogged defense
on urban fiery kept his dribble alive
tough shot
you don't need a three but you need a
store rats
he waved everyone away so he could get
the penetration good shot my tights to
get back in the play that time and get
the deflection Rivers try the lava to
compel
snap to tie the game patter back out
Durant to tie it
[Applause]
Kairi a bomb
[Applause]
[Music]
he was there to block the shot
[Applause]
feels out the ranted the crossover
came face-to-face and I think what
happens is everybody watching those
things so I got to be able to coach you
and tell you whether you're not getting
it done razzle-dazzle on a beautiful
advance feed from smart
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
looking to make a deal to somebody else
namely Kyrie Irving Irving to the basket
Irby a second to go stand up she could
read and react and they took the super
plays a lot of time
[Applause]
no Bulldog defensive player to make the
stops
Irving back to Horford Horford for three
ties the game
warriors +8 on the boards Durant gets a
running start inside hey it's Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you hit that subscribe button for
more videos